south of Savannah the waves of the
Atlantic break on the shores of the
Golden Isles of Georgia once the
rendezvous of Buccaneers
later seat of Richmond Oriole
plantations these islands have character
and charm witness the picturesque ruins
of the old slave hospital where Negro
slaves were treated more than a century
ago
westward the marshes of Blin
and the Sydney linear oak under which
the poet sat while he wrote the song
that have made these marshes famous on
the main its Harbor sheltered by the Sea
Island is the old town of Brunswick
county seat of Glynn County rich in
traditions important part of the Old
South thriving seafood and industrial
center of the new here are important
crab and shrimp fishery canneries to
preserve the catch for shipment one of
the South's largest wood pulp mills a
modern plant for distillation of pine
oil and other wood buy products are
thriving for their inbox industry
altogether giving employment to
thousands of workman Brunswick center of
a rural area is typical of communities
throughout America here a demonstration
in syphilis control can be carried on a
test program for work at other places
south or north the United States Public
Health Service joined with the health
department's of Georgia and Glynn County
to set up such a project this is not the
story of syphilis the disease it is the
story of Public Health Organization to
stamp out syphilis in Brunswick the work
resembles that of any City private
doctors are given free drugs to treat
all their cases of syphilis so that
those who can afford to pay but little
may go to their own doctors thus the
private physician treats those who can
afford to pay at all
at the health department a modern public
clinic treats 275 patients each week
free of charge systematic efforts have
been made to find syphilis bring it to
treatment blood tests are a part of
school health examination every child
here has already been tested in small
communities in the outlying region the
story is the same here at st. Simons 35
patients come to the clinic each week
and rural doctors receive free drugs and
financial aid for the treatment of
poorer patients just as do the doctors
of the town
but beyond the towns beyond the doctors
offices beyond even roads are the woods
this is a rural land a land of forests
fewer than 10 people to the square mile
deep in the piney woods
how will one reach these people I'll
reach those who work at Country sawmill
who gathered um from the pine trees and
tend the turpentine still here are
people who have neither means for travel
to urban centers nor leisure to travel
the health officer must reach these two
if he used to meet his responsibility
for the protection of the community if
this mountain will not come to Mohammed
Mohammed must go to the mountain hence a
mobile clinic that traveled throughout
three counties Camden Macintosh and
blimp
let's follow its journeys day by day
Monday a hundred and seven miles 106
patients Tuesday 110 mile 129 patients
Wednesday 102 miles 118 patients
Thursday 40 miles 40 patients Friday a
hundred miles 90 patients Saturday 60
miles 44 patients for the week 519 miles
527 patients at 24 clinics
this silver top is the symbol of the
service along the road the clinic self
becomes a bus to bring patients who live
at intermediate points to the treatment
center the clinic stop the patients
gather
next to church the biggest event of the
week
fine syphilis bring it to treatment that
is the story of control the treatment
renders the patient non-infectious stops
the spread of the disease through the
community
it's a far cry from the Swift and
shining trailer to the oxcart
but many come to the clinic in this way
while many more come on foot some
walking 10 miles or more for treatment
once a week or 70 weeks they gather at
that rural forum the country store to
compare notes on this new contribution
to the life of the community
the school bus serves in a new capacity
it brings more patients to the clinic
doctors on view the clinical methods of
the finest hospitals reach out to serve
Aurora Lyon inside the trailer is a
completely equipped clinic electric
sterilizers refrigerator fans and lights
are fed by a 110 volt generator in the
tow car no time is wasted and setting up
forward three minutes after arrival
treatment can begin
the clinic serves as a health center not
only for syphilis
this boy is being immunized against
typhoid fever at crowded stops the
county nurse sets up her stand nearby in
the forward part of the trailer blood is
taken for laboratory tests are span Amon
is administered to patients may be
treated at once here a specimen of blood
is taken for a test
our Fenneman injected into the blood
kills the germ of syphilis and the
patient can no longer transmit the
disease to other each patient gets
simply written detailed instructions so
that the illness will be fully
understood
behind the curtain in the rear of the
trailer is a complete examination room
with its own equipment and sterilizer
here bismuth is administered bismuth
prevents the tragic relapses of heart
and brain
at Health Department headquarters in
Brunswick darkfield examinations are
performed a little serum from the first
sore is examined under the microscope
this is the earliest possible diagnosis
for syphilis the earlier treatment is
begun the shore of the cure it would
take thirty five hundred of these
syphilis germs laid end-to-end to make
an inch spiral Peter paladin a killer at
large at Waycross 60 miles from
Brunswick Georgia has a modern branch
laboratory here blood tests are
performed for the Tri County project
tubes filled with blood specimens come
from the trailer from the Brunswick
clinic and from private physician an
automatic pipette measure serum into
test tubes for the calm test vein
laboratory technicians are essential
laboratories can't afford to make
mistakes let's see the result
negative no syphilis negative no
syphilis positive reaction note the
heavy particles in the tube that means
syphilis but one must be very sure let
us double check with a Wasserman test
that is another blood test for syphilis
technically a little different from the
car let's see what it will show a milky
fluid like this on the tube on the right
would mean syphilis the clear tube is a
check - and here are the tests watch the
tube on the right negative no syphilis
negative no syphilis positive here our
case of syphilis is verified even the
layman can see the difference in these
two two
the project is organized for finding
cases and holding them in treatment
it takes 70 weeks to ensure a cure for
syphilis even with free treatment it is
not always easy to keep patients coming
week after week the trailer helps but
there are four follow-up workers two
white and two colors
the house-to-house canvass has proved
also a most effective means of getting
blood specimen
behind the project - is education one
must carry the story to the people
midwives deliver 400 babies a year in
these counties well trained by the
Health Department they are licensed by
the state here they learn about the
blood test in actual demonstration they
carry forth the story and bring mothers
in for prenatal blood tests
the grocery man wraps up the clinic
announcement with every purchase
the country store shares a place among
its tobacco signs for clinic anvil
wherever the workers go they tell the
story of the clinic to willing ear how
bad blood makes people sick our destroys
heart and brain how it makes babies die
how the blood test finds it and how the
treatment is taken long enough is
certain cure
the blood test serves a double purpose
first it is a dragnet for syphilis
second it is an educational device blood
specimens are taken in the turpentine
wood at factory gates on the shrimp
floors at the docks of the porgy
fishermen a man who has seen the blood
test
loses his fear the man who hasn't had
one wants it everyone talks about it the
blood test becomes a demonstration and a
symbol eel faces its problem more
directly
honestly spontaneously than did its
father here the blood test carries its
message to a country dance or
but the greatest health comes from the
churches pastors are ever willing and
glad to cooperate they urge their people
to join in the program they tell them of
the disease which threatens health and
life and the generation yet unborn they
urged that the message will be carried
forth to the countryside that all may
know and walk in the light of Health
they themselves take the blood test as a
demonstration and urge their
parishioners to follow them such is the
story of a community mobilized a
community which met syphilis with the
weapons of medicine and modern public
health whatever you may do in your
community in these three counties of
southeastern Georgia the days of
syphilis are numbered syphilis will be
the next great plane to go
religion wasn't being that money caught
by we walking in the line or it would be
run before I will walk